hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of rent cafe rent cafe 37 here
at Anime uproar I'm Ana Mack your host
and today we have another bunch of cool
people we got animator econ back though
he loves being a guest that we like
having him on he always gets triggered
and it makes for good good
Kayson off to a great start we got our
boy Lotus joining us once again from the
nerd cornered corner what's up my man
was good ladies and gentleman how y'all
doing out there glad to have you again
Lotus with your black screen and then we
have a boys soul maka
what's up soul everybody it's me again
you don't know me homie boy I'm an ya
Lotus for some reason you're like
picture doesn't actually show up when
you talk it's just completely black
scream oh well that's peculiar let me
see if I can do anything about that
yeah whereas like recon like I have my
face shown obviously but we'll get recon
and sold in there like a lothario
so I don't know why that is but anyway
anyhow while we have people coming in
welcome everyone in the chat to another
episode of Grand Cafe in this we're
gonna be discussing the biggest of what
the [ __ ] moments it in anime and there
are quite a few I think quite a few out
there before we do get started though I
just want to thank everyone for almost
forty six thousand subscribers insane
I'm gonna start doing that drama alert
thing nowadays like not anime top
coordination now forty six thousand
subscribers strong white house seriously
guys thank you so much it's really means
a lot to us actually we had I asked last
week if that rant if they can get more
lights than the previous rent cafe and
it got exactly the same honor likes 149
likes for both so that was interesting
let's see if we can beat that this week
let me know guys if you liked these rank
of face drop a like make sure that you
let me know that you do like these retro
face because
we gonna keep him going 37 weeks in a
row now always such a blast having fun
great awesome people excellent stuff
guys consistent to cuz like I tried
doing content that's on a weekly basis
and I'm just I'm not up to snuff for
that so I had to give I gotta give the
channel props on that much oh thank you
yeah it is hard to be consistent but
with Rand cafe I feel like it's it's fun
it's not work it's fun right you just
mean right right and stuffing up so dad
helps obviously sometimes you oh man I'd
rather do something else or somebody
like no man actually every time I
actually start Branco felt like man this
is fun I what I love doing this so yeah
hope to keep it going as long as
possible of course if the people like it
if the people like it who wants to start
with their favorite what the [ __ ] moment
in anime I can start us off with one
let's do it all right so I don't know
how many of you out there have ever seen
Golden Boy right but it's a six-episode
series and there's one episode and it's
been quite some time since I've seen it
so I can't remember the names of and the
characters but there's this one female
character who shows up eventually right
and our main character he's a bit
perverse you know it's a little bit of a
hentai you feel me and he comes upon
this girl sees her on a motorcycle and
she's just like dry humping the [ __ ] out
of her motorcycle just like kind of
getting off - it was just like vibrating
in park and she's just like going to
town and just like oh this is the thing
this is happening and he just sit there
watching like oh well this is
interesting and all I could think of my
head that so much it's like yo what the
[ __ ] is going on golden golden boy it's
only six episodes but much like fully
Cooley it's full of gems and it's it's
got a few more so I kind of make you
touched your head to the side and
scratch your head like [ __ ] man I
actually had two ideas now pop into my
head for what the [ __ ] moments not that
you were talking one is with the whole
humping thing obviously the table kun
scene in code geass bro
just what such good what the [ __ ] right
there that wouldn't only came out of
nowhere it's like there was obviously
like an unhealthy obsession but that
that [ __ ] came out of left field
poor Nunnally poor blind wheelchair yeah
recon you don't want good enemy we know
no no I do anime mouth says finding out
animatic lives in Canada was of what the
[ __ ] moment when can people like snob -
shocking it's not that shocked and Lotus
your are you in Kerala - nah I live in
the States
ok ok I work in Canada that come to rank
of faith I guess I could say I'm the
German boy no good and talked the other
what the [ __ ] moment Lotus you might
know about this cuz it's from fully
coolly oh that you already know I know
but go on
when is it mom eg lemme me
yeah mommy me okay for some reason
forget she is sitting on the lemongrass
like by the bridge with our boy what was
his name again now - now I'll tell yes I
want to say cool down but that's from
elfin lead nada and Haruko is comes by
on the bike and she tells mommy me to
come with her and mommy just gets up
quickly and now it's a pulsar by
accident cuz she's going up so quickly
and pulls off her panties yeah what's
funny about that is that it happened so
quick and so smooth it's like it's
something that you might miss the first
time everybody I know I was like yeah
without even noticing it the panties are
on the ground there act like it didn't
happen I was like you guys talking about
Elfen Lied Oh talk about it that's
probably one of the biggest one of the
fun moments is when Lucy had the dog and
those cruel kids what can kill the dog
and blood splatter that's that's just
what the [ __ ] the anime if I'm being
honest cuz that's all I could think the
entire time I was watching yeah it's
like straight from episode 1 I'm like
you know yeah no yeah I mean I just said
the moment when my sister got ripped in
two on the train or whatever oh yeah
yeah what she's really like jealous in
it and she just tears your sister into
it yeah that more so what the [ __ ] did
you kill this father - yeah yeah yeah
and I'm super swamped
can we can we give some props to recon
for actually watching out the lead
because I'm positively surprised and
yeah definitely I think you said you
said that well
Lotus what the [ __ ] the enemy however I
the reason I love that anime is that
it's even though Lucy does such horrible
stuff when she's younger especially
because of this difficult situation
she's in
you still get to sympathize with her by
the end because you know what she's been
through and it's like she's not horrible
unforgivable things and you yet you
still sympathize with her as a character
which is I think speaks to the greatness
of the writers like the quality of the
writing there yeah I definitely feel you
on that how about how about this one of
the newest anime you guys know what I'm
talking about probably gonna cut that
one badge Allah yeah you actually write
about that that is another one is with
the finger suckin and that goes to
clockwork planet for the first episode
oh yes yuzu looking out those fingers
sounds like from the start episode 1
what
look hmm yeah looks like I got a new
series I gotta check out check it out
it's called clockwork planet and
speaking of that what what the [ __ ]
moment that I've done I was like I was
I'm not watching that anymore hand
shakers and the freakin haw saddle
masochistic girl and shakers does not
resist I wonder like I was like dude and
shakers never happened go hands did that
they didn't do that [ __ ] hurts I've got
two that come to mind the end of
evangelion she's literally you know it's
it's the mean you know everyone dies the
end literally also what the [ __ ] going
and then the ending well I mean it's a
good what the [ __ ] moment but the the
ending of zankyou no terror or Taran
resonance with the with the police
officers then and the helicopter turns
up moment right there that was like wow
that was it yeah yeah I mean but it was
a good one yeah yeah yeah and buys by
the way we have not stock who has just
joined us with a new avatar what's up
Knox nothing much how are you don't know
how long I'll be able to be here but
every moment counts absolutely my number
one rival welcome yes this is a really
not reciprocated ride Knox Ark is still
going on in Red Cafe I love it Knox tell
us tell us what are some of your
favorite what the [ __ ] moment and anime
and you've done a lot of sarcastic
trailers sarcastic facts so you know a
lot of what the [ __ ] moments um I think
that many moments that are perceived as
normal by most of us at this point are
WTF moments
I don't know if you've already mentioned
it because it's the first thing that
would come to my mind is that everyone
orgasms over everything whether its food
or it worshipping or its anything just
BAM yup were you talking them like the
back to like the fan base and stuff
because I've seen a lot of fan base
orgasm over faces that madara pools and
stuff in the ruins
it was rather shocking but yeah he's got
a point you have some pretty uh let's
just say more passionate fans who seem
to let one go every day just an
expression
yeah there's like cocky Louie is such a
great example of just like orgasm faces
for gambling like for example shokugeki
no souma I love that show and literally
half of its food porn I don't know if I
eat a hotdog it wouldn't happen to me
[Laughter]
and the person that's leaving the
drive-thru before me he takes a bite and
copper 20-piece and that first nugget
let's makes me let a load go I'm going
back to that McDonald's every time every
time I get it people would say that
like delicious like people do say that
that is how people get their food Gazans
ready
another thing once we're at the cute
little sister thing um incest yes the
second arc Nick victory fire bottle
kisses Regan yeah yeah no I know cuz
like you see we see the first arc like
okay here's the thing
why is Jesus cousin recon the biggest
what the [ __ ] is anyone that calls
someone else onii-chan makes it awkward
it's weird the end but not but the whole
the whole gun Gale online [ __ ] that
that's cool and all and it's when you
get to the to the latter half with the
little girl that he meets and then meets
and realized that [ __ ] that's just the
what the [ __ ] moment I forget what she
had she had some sort of disease yeah
hospital and she was you want a jewel or
whatever no that wasn't that that was
what the [ __ ] cuz I wasn't like it [ __ ]
got so heavy all of a sudden it's like
okay I was already hip to the you know
if you died again you die in real life
but this was like hey boy is this hit
too close to home this is this is real
like this this happens in real life not
necessarily a bad thing
no I I think that was completely what
the [ __ ] that art because if you look at
it they start going into a completely
different game based on Norse mythology
yeah I don't even remember in the gamers
when I was in that arc that was the the
Excalibur arc the three episode arc
before well yeah that's what I'm saying
the three episode arc sets up the whole
Norse mythology's thing and I'm doing
like oh this looks like a cool game cool
cool and then all of a sudden they just
go left field Ostrom eyes the main
character and they go into this it's
like they aborted that
art because it was too much budget or
something like last night because it was
terrible
that's why they climb falls in love with
the girl turns out the girl is a massive
ogre creature from the online world
that's a shock pork line forever alone
but me yeah I don't know the whole arc
was just
let's get cutie till more over power
than he already is yeah it's better if
he gets even more over power because
he's he's best boy he's only boy
okay could we please move the toothbrush
scene in the same monogatari oh yeah
that falls into what I was saying before
about the orgasms everywhere again
basically that the the older brother
then decides to inflict on his little
sister that's right that's right it's
both categories right she has to allow
him to brush her teeth
so she's laid there on his bed and then
he's brushing her teeth and you know the
way our bodies come Bowls in and you
know then the sweating and stuff and
yeah you know it probably has like three
million views by now yep on a Qatari
tooth pristine oh just come on just
watch the girl get so you know like I'm
not saying I'm looking but I'm not
saying I don't know hearing that it does
not at all give me the urge to watch it
it just means like it makes me say what
the [ __ ] is perfect I don't want to see
it but now I have to you're one of those
guys it's like oh man I gotta see it
yeah it's like it's like if somebody
points them out to me and I have a
saying like dawg it's so weird so
strange [ __ ] like I know I'm not
gonna like it but now I've gotta see it
cuz I feel left out
yeah but I'm not that guy I'm like no
[ __ ] I was here
speaking of [ __ ] it I don't want to see
it Joshua bull man brought up Tokyo
ghoul earlier and that is another that's
not what the [ __ ] the enemy that is what
the actual [ __ ] the anime I yeah like I
got to like the first seven eight
episodes and I was saying what the [ __ ]
so much it all's I can't even watch this
anymore man like cannibalism like weird
like sexual pleasure derived from
cannibalism attempted masochism just see
yeah no I'm not a I'm not a very
squeamish guy usually you know I'm
pretty tough you know I can handle my
own it's all the cannibalism all the
blood and gore [ __ ] is whatever like
it's a damn it no biggie but the funnel
like torture scene at the end ever saw
one that [ __ ] had me like oh when he put
the [ __ ] in uh most like a centipede or
some [ __ ] in in conic easier I was like
is that's where I draw the line
yeah yeah I got a snob no I feel you
100% I couldn't get through that I was
[ __ ] speaking of don't Evangelion which
saw you brought up earlier another scene
of course from Evangelion which plenty
of scenes there but the Asuka in
hospital scene oh my god that was that
made me turn right off I seen that and I
was like no way I'll forget this what
the [ __ ] is this the way Jing Jie starts
falling there well she's like in a coma
or whatever yeah people try to convince
me shinji is a powerful protagonist like
the very first episode of one of the
like movies or something you know like
cuz I was the main series then there's
like those end of evangelion and there
knows that up one dust I was like right
at the beginning and yeah yeah that was
just yeah it's crazy it's crazy
I'm say schooldays also at the end when
the main character got killed
and chopped completely point-o bag and
in the end we see the girl just hugging
his head that was alright but that
happens like seven or eight times an
openly enemy or you guys bought a couple
into a bag wow this isn't counted as a
spoiler either cuz no one should really
go watch it right yeah
yeah after after give a shout out to use
it Gabrielle Juarez who mentioned anime
she coolly I don't know if you guys have
seen that yeah that's yeah she's trying
to sing yeah so yeah she Kui is this
awesome samurai anime and there is some
very crazy scenes a lot of disturbing
scenes in there but one one oh no let's
see the one in particular I'm thinking
of would be the one where the girl's
father bevor crazy possessive guy you
know believing in Puri annuda then
decides to attack he's his own daughter
and force himself on her that was yeah
something someone's getting forced on in
the background that souls daughter and
that's actually her singing naughty yeah
she's got a beautiful voice singing
voice little deeper there yeah which
should be a little bit deeper but yeah a
lot of messed up scenes uh going back to
sword art online because lord knows we
have it girls
what a Familia and the chat we are not
moving on because tentacle scene in
sword art online oh my god Oh pickle
scenes in yeah yeah that one yeah which
it has hacked the console oh yeah yeah
you know to be honest I had uh
officially suppressed those memories
that that even happened and now remember
that that was a thing so which one the
one with the lolly all of it oh I forgot
that that [ __ ] even happened it's sorta
oh yeah like you you you can't you can't
do that hold blocking memories out to to
help yourself feel better at rank of
Fame we relive all the traumatic scenes
all of them I see well my wounds are
open carrying on yeah gun scans has a
few WTF scenes is all guns I don't know
if you guys have seen that or Gant
zero have you seen that movie I've seen
it's good he's good the guy the big fat
guy who's in the group you know one of
hospice friend the big fat guy the guy
about the little sisters yeah this guy's
just always into little girls and in the
latest episode he was watching a [ __ ]
video of a girl liking a dog okay that's
your problem
had you met the nogal yes that's the
biggest problem you may not like the
first episode the guy just kneeling
there staring at her undergarments while
he's pleading with her to become his
girlfriend that's not weird
no recon on this Knox I actually think
Roger at the Nogales funny I agree it's
funny but honey OD want cards is funny
practice talking one at a time okay but
yeah I think it's actually funny
but I do agree with with like obvious
it's unrealistic but I think it's funny
and I think I thought it was a nice
switch up where she actually says yes
she'll go out with him because he was
like oh she's never it's never gonna
happen I was like seven and a half buddy
and then she's like yes I'll go with you
I thought that was kind of funny and
like an interesting rule twist but yeah
like with um with recon with those guys
that are like into lollies as friends
entire anime how'd you meet - no gal not
that I don't like it cuz I like it just
like I like she'll get it okay not like
I like shokugeki no souma but I like it
as a guilty pleasure anime but yeah a
lot of it was weird but I still like
with that fat dude like I was like bro
you need medical help you know it keeps
on repeating over and over again the
first episodes like okay that's okay
second episode okay this needs to cut
down third episode it's not funny
anymore fourth episode yeah well the
[ __ ] is going on jarring it's like what
the [ __ ] is going on like this isn't
normal like you can't enjoy the M and
when you have some [ __ ] like you have
around like are we gonna pretend this is
like normal now so ya know and become a
problem if that's gonna keep going on
like how can you enjoy the anime when
that [ __ ] keeps you like your wise name
of [ __ ] arrest in this - this season
have you mentioned traps yet next is a
little trap no no but while we are dirt
one yeah we mentioned the main voice
actor in a hydrometer nogal eeeh voices
Junichi an English dub so so - my homie
Alejandro aka kakie films
nice I don't know what that is but shut
up he's a rising voice actor i
Funimation na he's got a few roles but
yeah he plays Junichi Anna
how'd you meet a so nice guy I know a
lot of the youtubers they know the voice
actors in some of our youtubers which is
really cool I don't personally know them
but yeah for sure that's cool I can
voice act if you need an guy with
Eastern European accent alright well I
need her
order I need a reporter for my boruto
abridged here let's hear you say
something what we want to say no soul
Lord Hokage what's your opinion on
fidget spinners and you want me to say
that in Russian accent I want you to say
it as best as you can
oh by the way he charges $500 per
episode knocks don't put me on the spot
I'm his manager and I'd take 10% Lord
Hokage what's your opinion on fidgets
spinners Lord Hokage what is your
opinion on fidgets spinners all right
I'll go back to you after the video okay
you can let me down gently it's cool no
it's good it's good well we'll have to
you know confer privately all right cool
cool sounds good guys sorry for the
little delay where do we do some
business but I wanted to mention other
than what the [ __ ] like terrible
terrible [ __ ] that we've mentioned
there's also shriya sharma mentioned the
potato chip scene in Death Note which is
a what the [ __ ] blowing but in like a
cool way like it's like yellow what the
[ __ ] smells cool now see that was like a
soft what the [ __ ] we kind of like
chuckle and smarter so over
intensification of the simple master and
servant together thoughtful and yes
definitely weird yes
lightning darkness wants a shutout
what's up man we don't welcome status
sure yeah I didn't think that that what
the [ __ ] moments would follow this
easily when I came up with the topic but
there is just so much everybody so much
and in the Chad guys feel free to keep
suggesting good what the [ __ ] moments I
got another one for you that's from
Golden Boy this was this was a little
more disgusting and I try to think about
it because it kind of makes me want to
gag a little bit when I do but a so
there's another scene in Golden Boy and
as I said before the MCS pretty perverse
right
and he did something to anger a girl and
he's like on the ground or some [ __ ]
like he probably got knocked out at some
point and she goes to spit on him and he
opens his mouth that sticks out his
tongue and catches on his tongue
I like yo what the [ __ ] is rock with
this dude is it weird I'm not disgusted
I mean I've seen worse it is not the
worst thing the work is like obviously
if you've kissed you know a girl before
a guy or whatever it is that you're into
it's like you know you use that exchange
has happened but it's it's I don't know
something about to me like witnessing it
happened that way was like okay that's
[ __ ] haven't seen the scene I don't
want to see it though like it's an older
anime so it's like it's only but so many
ways like show saliva right it's just
pure white so it doesn't exactly look
like saliva one day it's his tongue
either so that's also something to keep
in mind from re0 oh yes yes bring that
up by the way girl bro not a fan of
fidget spinners not so fired up is in
the shot as well
Nick victory fire says the sniper shot
from high school to dead
I assume mold of matrix boobs Lord is
she getting weaved bro you getting weed
as I was saying I don't know I like it
his way better that the biggest one the
[ __ ] moment for me in Reiser was Rams
body being twisted by best I love your
opinions and everything but I loved that
moment I hated it
Felix was the biggest in that one no
that was another one those suits that
was hard to watch because I for me the
biggest moment in reezy row that pissed
the hell out of me was when he said I
love Amelia that wasn't that wasn't even
on what the [ __ ] moment but it triggered
more than there's this whole speech the
whole episode I think was episode 18 the
whole episode 18 was a speech and like
this long speech from Rennes finally
brings Subaru back he could have at
least like said it gently and he just
like puts his arm on RAM and says listen
screw you I like Amelia like you finish
you done I cool no but that made perfect
sense to me because to me it makes
perfect sense why he loves Amelia over
REM and you guys know that that is what
I think and yeah best girl and story but
but let's not get into this again we've
had special streams just arguing about
this
what the [ __ ] moments in read zero week
on the whole REM being tortured thing
complete what the [ __ ] moment also the
whole puck turn it into like Godzilla
and like that whole the whole episode
was such a what the [ __ ] yeah that [ __ ]
and this so it's like alrighty what's
going on here it switches like genres
like it switches genres cousin goes from
like from like you know a fun fantasy
colorful anime to like a black and white
horror wife like three zeros one of my
favorite anime at this point it probably
and I know it has a lot of hate and I
even made a sarcastic trailer on it
against my better judgment but it was so
requested but I really really liked that
show I mean I think it was good but I
don't love it nearly as much as a lot of
people seem to and I think that if and
when there's every season two they've
got a lot of ground to cover in order
for me to justify season one so there's
just a lot of [ __ ] that I had issues
with or I got questions about if I don't
get some answers there's gonna be hell
to pay
I'm gonna have serious problems but uh I
think it was okay it was pretty good
how about back one I don't know if you
guys watched packet 1 the 3-0 what the
[ __ ] moments not done yulux licking
Subaru's ear
yes the whole Felix was one big I was
like no okay he's a trap like we're used
to traffic by now but like the ears he
was like what the [ __ ]
then then Priscilla scene when he's like
kissing her feet and [ __ ] feet that was
also like that think about it Nick look
if I says darkness from Kosuke no Suba
and I agree
darkness is hilarious think oh hello but
it's like yeah sup girl have you seen
the second OVA from re0 from Kona Suba
I'm sorry not yet so that has one hell
of a darkness scene Oh excellent so I
have to watch it darkness is best girl
no comment no shut up recon also can't
be best girl in coma soon the first aqua
fan I've met recon man it's right now
dark the darkness is not she's not the
best girl I would say mega mean
for Dorne it means bad Marilyn mega
means best girl for me man I love that
other than explosions then Lally
explosions and then watch her collapse
when you say that all the explosions
have been her passing out out like that
was not what the [ __ ] at all yeah I mean
like you said darkness best girl I was
like no mega mean his best girl man your
reasoning was pretty what the [ __ ] I'm
not gonna lie to you
well I loved the explosions man sold
back me up
back to be honest God's explanation for
why he thinks megameters best girl was
the embodiment of what the [ __ ]
I wasn't even talking about what the
[ __ ] I'll back you the only thing I can
say about [ __ ] Co no super because I
fell asleep in the second episode and
that's because I got on it is Lonnie
what the [ __ ] moment was how he died
ha ha ha ha that was yeah that was it
that was yeah that was a funny one yeah
that was dumb I like that beginning
because it's poking fun of like look at
the animate this season obviously came
after kono Suba but like the whole
nights of magic and a sekai no
smartphone like the way he they get to
that world is so random and stupid and
just like randomly die and it's like oh
yeah now you're in a different world
if gonna suit would actually make fun of
it because he dies in such a stupid way
but it's like yeah I get this is satire
and I enjoy it for what it is right no
here's the thing in nights of magic they
kill off the main character instantly
without any explanation and it's like
how a smartphone they barely explained
why he died he's just so like yeah God
can I please have my smartphone for you
yeah thanks I mean so what the [ __ ]
quite wide the smartphone even works
what does it work was like ah yeah
where's the gate reception from God
where your bar is coming from yeah you
see in reesy row he had a cell phone
that somehow lasted forever and that
didn't have God powers I don't know I
think I made less sense your dog you
just my [ __ ] mind that [ __ ] the both
the ice and the watermelon I just want
to point out that this clear gaping
bottle was pointed out by a guy who says
he loves re0 for some reason I love
breezy row great show yeah I made a
sarcastic trailer on it I had five
minutes to fill of crap unreal
we had acknowledged the flaws is
something they love oh yeah that's right
I can't acknowledge any flaws in Gurren
Lagann so I guess I have to your enliven
there's also no flaw why so I feel you
although no fact I'll get triggered I'll
get recon
you mentioned the potato chip seen
before yeah can you please watch Joe
Joe's you're not even diamond is
unbreakable yet listen here my [ __ ] we
only up to die I'll read the mom cuz I
don't read scares we only up to part
three but anyway speaking of some Joe
Diaz alright so I'm almost done with
part three I'm all like it so get the
hell to you guy that what greatest
button moment the the first the first
moments in this series or at least in
part three that made me go what the [ __ ]
was I kakoen he gets possessed or
something I forget exactly how it went
down
like it was either a body double or a
possession or whatever it was but the
same he's like licking the cherry and
[ __ ] like bouncing it on his tongue and
like don't always like that [ __ ] I'm
just like kill what the [ __ ] is this
show man like and there's so many other
moments in this series I I feel like
jojo's bizarre adventure at times goes
out of its way to just be obviously as
bizarre as [ __ ] possible and I love
the hell in it it literally puts time
and effort into going out of its way to
just be as weird and it is like
off-putting and disgusting sometimes as
possible you got like eyeballs melting
into people's mouths and you got to see
my love when those two guys wanted to
Bob Dole and polnareff want it to bond
by pissing in the tube in the guy's
mouth right that's another one and then
it really is like this perverse and
they're just like laughing it up while
like pissing down the dudes mouth I'm
just like oh this is the thing or when
they fed the baby the thing yeah yeah
like mixed it up into the baby food
actually ah I really I really did like
those couple episodes Oh cause death 13
like that Stan I thought that was really
cool I liked
no lolly hoe like that [ __ ] was funny I
cracked me up every time but JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure is it's all haidle
speaks volumes I know look you gave me
you haven't either you're the one guy
that I'm counting on to see everything
now here's the thing I can say I finally
get why you get that vibe right away the
way they poses are amazing to eight
knuckles on each finger and he twists
them on his face yeah whereas covers
like his entire face yeah you know I was
gonna watch Jojo sometime in the future
but not during your si yo one you put a
[ __ ] video clip of some random guy
roll the [ __ ] his name is putting a hand
yes no one is here to share the
awesomeness of diamond is a break
watching that I was like that guy is
probably in the five best villains anime
has ever made is it oh you will JoJo's
bizarre very cannot listen listen watch
it after all what they've been talking
about it sounds so bad with you at this
point are I'm saying it's good and I
have seen it you're saying it's not that
great and you haven't seen it mean well
just all the talking that you guys are
doing about the show and all the
spoilers just it just sounds I don't
know it definitely has some really
discussing moments but it's an acquired
taste I think the more like the more you
watch the better it gets and you just
get to a point like I I just I can't
stop watching better 100% the beginning
it seems weird and like the character
design and the way they speak it's all
just manner but at the end what I think
that's really engaging for me Waypoint
you're waiting for every episode so
a unique style to it it has like four
seasons it's quite a lot yeah we'll see
some one into kind of like or parts 1 &
2 they're kind of combined it's like one
one thing and then you have part three
which is like two seasons of it so cuz
I'd like a total 48 episodes and part 4
I think it's 39 I mean it's not like one
piece of [ __ ] listen you could do that
[ __ ] like two three weeks and no sweat
nothing we do that in our sleep
I've lost over 200 episodes of fairy
tale because I can't find the movie
anymore anyway I do think that we should
be open-minded with anime got some stuff
that looks really really weird as like
what the hell ends up being very cool
and funny in my opinion fooly cooly 2 as
an example of it's like what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah reason I mean but then there's
a lot to that it's a lot of hashtag [ __ ]
but uh by the way Luna mentioned the art
scene from killer kill which I get it
however to me the mom scene was the
biggest what the [ __ ] moment bar none of
killer killed what his heart must be
good though I think it's when you see
that like her heart is all made up alike
completely taken over by the fibers the
only at fibers what about power sight I
don't know if you guys watched it
parasite another one bites parasite it's
the guy who it gets possessed by this
[ __ ] virus in his body and all like
oh all of his body can turn into like so
good ya know I've been the best what the
[ __ ] one when in parasite was in the
manga you know when the hand was
interested in how they we produce oh
yeah
there the girl basically his hand by
itself when she looks away
he looks round to his hand and his hands
turn into a giant dick know this amazing
senses yeah yeah that's why so loves his
manga like they can't what he turned
into or did they just like block it out
of like how they handle it yeah
somewhere I will somewhere I will do
comparisons like so you can see
differences because there's a lot
there's a lot of differences like with
elfin and light often like there's a
whole other personality to Lucy which
you are not seeing she's actually got
three personalities a inner I mean
there's Lucy that we know there's the
new you know the innocent version that
she used but then as the evil version
this insider yeah I mean well this is
news to me it's completely different she
like it's basically a big attack comes
she ends up using her powers so much
like to first save the guy's life color
cuz he gets shot so she uses her powers
first to save his life then after all
these missiles are coming cuz they're
just looking to kill Lucy they don't
care who's there
so she's then using all her powers and
the evil side starts taking over so
she's looking now to let destroy the
world those invisible hands going
everywhere taking out buildings planes
everything and then eventually when like
the army move in on her all our bodies
like melted away and her body just kind
of like hovering
would have her face missin and stuff she
really must I'll catch you guys later
I have to go alright narcs thank you
take it easy pleasure to meet you Lotus
recon of course watch afterwards for all
our also co.labs knocks yes working on
it
yeah and knocks his link is in
description as a YouTube channel
one day Seoul will as well I'm sure and
yes Seoul thank you for telling me not
to read the [ __ ] awfully mugger cuz
that sounds terrible and thank you so
much for having me
my pleasure my friend alright I'll see
you next time okay I'm here moments oh
yes yes the high school of the bed
moment when Tom the main guy is carrying
down little girl on his shoulders and
she pisses down as yeah he's just
whatever you do just don't make us fall
over this edge right that was a good
moment like to do something you know
you're just not gonna think about you
know you know me I don't I don't care
peace in my have you after something we
make yeah that's it look look look it's
as much as you need to couldn't make it
out of here alive oh yeah the other one
in as well was I think yeah the first
episode where there's the two girls
running their friends and I all will be
friends forever yeah and I'm wanting the
best oh yeah yeah she betrayed her
[Laughter]
here's the thing that they say you got
to do what you got to do survive that's
what you gotta do yo but she split up on
her so fast bro yes yeah about life man
makes you to reevaluate [ __ ] it's like
which of my friends will turn on me I
don't know that's wild oh dude that had
a few what the [ __ ] one was a lot more I
think about it I'm about due for every
watch of high school to dead yeah like
they never made more unfortunately they
never will arrest a piece of desk I saw
you pass they could do more because
there's still more of the manga out
there because eventually I've got the
money and it's only like an extra volume
or so which at most like it gives like
300 yeah ODEs if they really stretch I
mean yeah you can do that though they
could have done it in the beginning but
the reason why I didn't continue digas
because at that time an earthquake
happened near the company's place so the
work was like corrupted and all this
stuff so they did they couldn't do it a
second season so that's why and now we
know that the director of high school
the Dead has died so I don't think an
OVA or a second see is gonna happen
anytime soon I don't ever get any more
that's called the dead content
unfortunately well no I mean they could
do they could do that cuz I mean look
we've still got content for Astro Boy
and I'm pretty sure to create as dead oh
yeah Sami Tezuka I mean yeah he's long
but it's different though where this is
like an incomplete work that was like it
was there was supposed to be more and it
was on indefinite hiatus and now it'll
never come back because he passed away
yeah I I think it's a different
situation whereas this is something like
people I don't even know how I would
explain the way I see it in my head but
it it's just different to me because
well somewhat it's more like a respect
thing where people want to carry on the
legacy whereas this it's more like
people want it more for their own
selfish reasoning as opposed to like oh
let's let's continue on his work or
something like that at least that's the
way I kind of see it
okay I want more high school that as
much as anybody but I just I just don't
see it happening but if it does happen I
definitely support that should 110% I
got the blu-ray I got the OVA I got the
seven volumes of the manga that we only
ever got I mean the manga continue right
is the mono continue just a little bit
more chapters like the the fat guy ends
up me in a gallery likes who's please
Foreman oh okay God is his name Cocteau
I think is it like to see your
continuation but I don't know if it's
actual gonna happen but guys don't
forget that if you like rank of a matrix
boobs leave a like on this video to let
us know
also Ryan mentioned and I saw other
people mentioning as well oh well
Alchemist as a what the [ __ ] movement
Nina oh right with the dog yeah about
that you do this now us that was not one
of those cool like I'd forgotten what
the girls name was but yeah about that
yeah I think he was also what the [ __ ]
of then coming to the realization that
he done this chimera experiment thing
with his wife previous is whoa dude nice
dude it's like oh what a nice rule are
they're not seen arrow moccasin say
heard of it and I've heard of them what
the [ __ ] scene I think her name is mega
Mia she comes into his door and she said
I love dicks she says that I was like
what oh yeah I think I actually saw a UH
which I didn't even know some era manga
because I haven't read
watching myself but I saw an image on
Twitter if like someone like screenshot
one of the scans or something it's like
but it has that page it's like yeah all
girls my age I was like you know what I
thought was a crazy
what the [ __ ] moment wasn't an end but
like recently when when the creator of
urea nice announced that Anya and Viktor
are gonna end up getting married like I
thought I was like you know I wasn't
even aware that but I guess that's
because I just can't be asked to be
interested in anything you're on ice
related woody what do you like so much
about it cuz to me to me that was a that
was a really really mediocre to subpar
series and I feel like it it I just I
just loved the relationship between the
characters especially Victor and year
AME and throughout the entire series it
was so well done but it was the I just
want to say I love you to the author
he wrote the entire thing so well lovely
relationship between the characters
element you you're a character icon
you're quite the character everybody
knows that I am a true ed Sheeran king
like you like insane or edgy harem anime
and then you like oh my erotic
ice-skating and then you like fairy tale
I don't know you've got an interesting
palette there yeah I don't I don't like
ones on I like tons of genres but my
most one is HD harem but I would say
boku no pico as long as it's all what
the [ __ ] you know oh we don't talk about
that well obviously I mean that's what
we let that one fester in the corner
over there where it belongs
yeah we're not gonna talk about like
boku no big or like ten times you don't
like and I want the [ __ ] moments I'm
sure we wouldn't know because none of us
watch hentai right guys
right
no watches every ecchi ever except you
have you better just doesn't go over and
I just swear it draws the line you know
this is crazy
I just know raising I like housing
making oh god that's that's all wall
standby bottom it's good so yeah yeah
yeah Sharia says Code Geass season three
announcement was what the [ __ ] last
November yeah that was definitely a you
nah lie that [ __ ] before a [ __ ] cuz
that's one of those suits because
obviously we all have plenty of anime
that we've seen that only ever got one
season or maybe even two seasons yeah I
switched it was more coal gas is not one
of those series
I [ __ ] love coke yes but that ending
was perfect so when a season three got
enough I was like you know that would be
like I would compare it to like Cowboy
Bebop or like full-on Alchemist
Brotherhood of getting another season
their story's done wait what are you
doing here they I thought we already
could it was finished definitely yeah no
that was one news or one that came out
opposed to the old discord boku no kind
of joke my jammy zucchini shoujo [ __ ]
knockin my girlfriend is a faithful
virgin [ __ ] that's getting a TV anime
when I saw that tire I beg your pardon
you wanna reiterate that one for me
pervades this also so title is my
girlfriend is a faithful virgin [ __ ]
alright yes that's the one yeah I'm
actually looking forward to that yes I
bet you are
no I haven't no it's just I saw that so
for Wow you know surprise
I have never imagined there would be any
kind of anime coming up all right now
just just based off the title alone I
gotta check this really going on here
another thing is in attack on Titan
there's a lot of like crazy looking
Titans that are kind of like what the
fog like that one berserk Titan like
it's just like running like a mania but
also the whole and by the way if you
haven't seen season two you never
thought I would
what are you waiting for it's not my
fault okay if you get spoiled but the
scene with Reiner and Bert Sol just
casually telling Aaron oh by the way
Aaron
yeah just like casual Nico I know by
that time I didn't read the manga and I
was watching like but now I've read the
whole longer I couldn't wait any more
but like at that time I didn't that was
dropped I was it was like so casually
what what did he just say it wasn't like
it was like in such normal conversations
like you
you almost might have missed it if you
weren't really paying attention like all
did this take it just skip back to the
[ __ ] huh oh yeah I know
yuck Rika missed it in his lot reaction
first which is understandable but then
people were hating on him that he missed
it like in the comments and share yeah I
mean people in the live reaction
commedia sometimes they get pissed off
and you make one mistake one simple
mistake like some sort of actually they
just get so pissed I don't know 100 to
200 this length I mean it happened to
Anna Mac as well once he said at the end
to Aaron Aaron
transform I've seen like almost video
game hot over a hundred dislikes I was
like really
no yeah reaction [ __ ] is just why
because it's like people watch reaction
videos only to get have people say that
like get the same reactions that they
would get and if you five different
reactions there if you're a [ __ ]
idiot it's like what a [ __ ] respect
alright it's time to start my live
wracking channel where I react slowly to
the polar opposite over the popular
reaction oh man just the treatment you
will get so many dislikes I'll give all
talk about the you know you're just like
Austin authentical scene perfect okay
perfect timing perfect you know the
right thing at the right time man loved
it loved it open my eyes know in
fullmetal and I'm just like hating it
the entire time like it's so [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's horrible art animation like
who the [ __ ] wrote this [ __ ] monkey LOM
King says he does reactions good luck to
you my man good luck to you he don't get
all the reactions for fun like you know
Corgi house stuff just come chatting
with you I'm not doing any [ __ ]
reactions like reaction channel stuff
[ __ ] - I do reaction for fun just to
express my opinion but when I do
reactions to like series that are less
known like the newest ones are currently
airing not like the sequels and all this
stuff I do tend to good you know
just watch the episode are you watching
a reaction any of you guys see ya Black
Lagoon yes
I never what the [ __ ] moment I would say
is uber when she turns up as a mate in
in the bar like full of all those
gangsters and everything and she
basically just takes everyone out and
starts chasing after the car like like
she's freaking savage yeah I don't know
to me that wasn't what the [ __ ] to meet
them what the [ __ ] was those twins those
Romania vampire twins know one of the
creepiest [ __ ] things I've ever seen in
animals what they both boys
we don't know they were just like [ __ ]
they were switching and genders and yeah
so [ __ ] it was so cuz I folio both boys
and they just wanted them decides to
pose as a gala and then I'll just swap
we don't know they just walk like we
don't know what their actual gender is
we have no idea and it's so creepy so
Emma its 2017 there gender-fluid okay
preteen murderer vampire twins I don't
see an issue they were taken out in
style though I did like the way Ballack
I took her took him out kind of stylish
kind of sweet in a way as well
when she sat with him on the bench you
know like like she's basically giving
him a hug and then they just snapped
from distance what about water in arms
everything about the twins was so
there's no sexist no I mean kissing
sister to suit sisters and the stuff
that they do to the guy I'm pretty sure
that's what the [ __ ] with the body
pillow over the chocolate mistake and
all this stuff I mean don't you guys
think so well I uh I am a man of culture
that's what still never seen kisses it's
not had time don't worry
by the way I'm really angry a really
angry what the [ __ ] moment was the
ending of iron blood and orphans I don't
want to talk about it Oh piss me off so
much I don't even want to like I want to
forget that like I want to black that
[ __ ] out like Lotus like you do those oh
wow like I love that show until the end
you know and then I was just like what
did I regatta dolphins have a manga by
any chance no
also speaking of terrible endings How I
Met Your Mother
terrible ending but no absolutely is it
also an anime called no no the anime
then says you know you should know then
sexy The Legend of the legendary heroes
oh my god that was terrible wait like
the way that ended it was like the story
had just started yeah I mean it's like
they just started building up set up for
what's going on and then next thing you
know and literally you just came to know
the characters like one thing happens
you're the main character an antagonist
you know to like kind of get their their
fight like realized you know just
started there's Nova characters then
setting up an alliance to assist the
main character and then it ends that's
it
so you get and I was like what was was
the rest of it where the hell is the
rest of it terrible it was terrible
yeah another similar situation is with
School Rumble the ending of School
Rumble where nothing is resolved it's
just such a terrible terrible ending
that it's just like you love the
characters it's hilarious throughout the
journey is great but then they get to
the point it's like oh why why chikubi
was kind of like that as well as as much
as it was good the ending sucks cuz you
got the to like main characters that
world antagonists and you know the
protagonists you see them there how they
are in their state like in the future
now because the whole story is told in
their past then and there they're
squaring off for a final fight but then
you never see that fight that fight
never happens you see them they're ready
to square off then you jump back and you
learn their story so that you think okay
after we're gonna go
we're finance nope it just ends just
anything you like wait it's a wrap
oh you thought there was more my creep
asks if the manga School Rumble has a
different ending no I don't think I
think that's the same ending it's just
that the manga went on for longer so
what the anime did they should have had
three seasons to cover everything but
they are too then they kind of skipped
to an OVA
which was the ending so you didn't see
all the development all season three
that should have been happening
however the ending was closed it
unfortunately so yeah School DxD
I haven't seen it like I've seen a few
seen it that seemed like something I
might actually like God why are we right
up my alley with the comedy mouse said
that when I went from 13 case up to 45
case subbed in less than two months that
wasn't what the [ __ ] yeah that was what
if I've ever seen it
yeah I agree but hey not complaining
thanks everyone for your support all
right I think we could wrap it up guys
we've been at it for a while it's been
fun like I said we did not run out of
what the [ __ ] moments talking about
whatsoever
they've just been flying all over the
place before we go I'll have you all you
guys and you know introduce yourself say
who you are and what you do and of
course if you like ran cafe drop you
like to let us know and you can join us
in the discord server link in the
description if you want to check out all
the daily chats that we have contests
flag contest writing contest coming up
very funny
Lotus to you my friend I supposed a
legitimate the names Lotus the kid who
never knows best you can check me out
over on my channel the nerd cornered
corner where I like to do a lot of
videos with its anime manga whether that
be manga tags longer discussions haul
videos playing anime related games like
Dragon Ball xenoverse or the new Naruto
shinobi Stryker game when that comes out
it's definitely catch about Dragon Ball
Fighters whenever that releases and yeah
I also do a couple of other you know
minor things here and there like I've
got a couple side videos that are a
little more artsy and creative that
kinda have to do with anime and manga
but they're more of a lot
actually kind of thing that I've just
doing my own spare time but uh yeah I'd
like to think I diverse amount of
content on my channel it's all for the
most part mostly anime and manga related
in some way or another but uh yeah
that's what you can find over on my
channel yeah Dragonball Fighters hype
hell actually waiting to play that as
well hell yeah I'm trying to be a Evo
next year main stage boy 28mph boy low
so we'll follow your progress hell yeah
um sold to you because we can always
have to go oh yeah okay alright so yeah
everyone yes so you know me entire is
the doji now is working on doing a
visual novel and I'm always on a discord
you'll find me there when I do
eventually have my channel set up
properly I'll probably announce it there
anyway
in discord so if you want to speak with
me more find me there so it's good my
man you know I always do Sol helps a lot
with the channel on this chord he's
always recommending stuff in our anime
manga and manga recommendations channel
he's always discussing anime theories
shutting people's theories it down if
they're not well thought-out like that
and also he helps me consult with me
about like certain scripts and stuff
that I know he's a really well-informed
about an anime or a manga that I asked
him for advice so yeah he's always
helping out thank you soul
and now to anime recon the man with a
diverse diverse food I'm actually
excited to to know more about your
visual novel and soul because it sounds
interesting but I don't know what it's
about it's about time no it's not no
it's well I can't wait to play I might
need is it free or paid well guess it we
free I guess to get out there yeah so
have like a have it free and then like
really well drawn women and be like and
if you wanna get the extra hentai no see
playboy not underestimate how much
people will pay for that [ __ ] on the DLC
pack and you like let's go be $9.99
they'll pay ya already with grow
animations my gift if like a code via
the cone yes creators like oh we'll have
a special hentai version of corneas see
right now I Levi I'm not well-versed in
the entire genre it's not really my
forte my cup of tea but if they won't go
ahead drop some code geass and I'm gonna
need somebody to slide without like blah
blah yeah Cornelia I like the women what
up is your boy recon you know me I do
dim reactions seasonal daily for the new
anime every season and I do them quality
top tens
amb styles check out my channel go ahead
and subscribe cuz I don't give a [ __ ]
but if you're welcome to join the
community then go ahead he left the mic
today really drop the mic you just drop
the mic find a bear in the Chairman I
haven't seen you in a while did I
disconnect
alright recon is too late you left it's
over oh I just connected [ __ ] yeah thank
you for joining us everyone in the chat
my guest here always a pleasure to hang
out with you guys I drank a favor back
next week hopefully every week forever
until the end of time because we will
obtain code or you know download our
cell
digitally or some [ __ ] so we're gonna be
doing this all the time but yeah thanks
guys
until next time see us bass Cowboys I
love you all
bang